President Trump will meet with
Republican and Democratic members of
Congress today to discuss potential gun
control legislation the president says
he supports raising the age limit to
legally buy certain firearms school
safety policy proposals could also be
unveiled this week West Virginia
Democratic Senator Joe Manchin will
attend the White House meeting five
years ago he co-sponsored a bill with
Senator Pat Toomey a Republican to
expand background checks and strengthen
the national background check database
he spoke with us at the time this is a
great step we closed down the loopholes
on gun shows we stopped any so-called
loopholes on internet sales we've really
gotten a hold of what we've done and
we've done it right the Senate rejected
that measure twice Senator Joe Manchin
is with us from Capitol Hill
senator good morning good morning John
in these debates about guns in America
what often happens from gun rights
supporters is they say none of the
measures that are being put forward
would actually have done anything to
stop the attack that they are being
offered in response to so in everything
that's been discussed is there something
you see that it is a response and would
have done something to perhaps prevent
or stop what happened John I just think
the mindset change right now we're
seeing a movement we've never seen
before we're seeing it from children you
know I thought about when you and I
probably went to school the most thing
we feared about going to school where we
ready for our math or our English test
and how well would we do on it now
they're concerned about you know their
own safety and I have grandchildren in
the school system in West Virginia I'm
concerned and I think everyone else
these kids have spoken up corporate
America has woke up and people are
speaking out they want common sense they
want things that make common sense and
for those people the manchin-toomey bill
was a bill that did not threaten Second
Amendment rights it protected the Second
Amendment rights but it also said if
there's a commercial transaction and you
don't know that person don't you think
that we ought to have the background
check if you go to a guns a gun show or
on the internet where the al Qaeda and
the terrorists have said hey if you want
to do harm you want to get arms go into
the gun show that's all we're talking
about it's changing the loopholes in
commercial sales as wherever they may
happen gun shows an Internet
but senator background checks weren't at
issue in this case were they and what
when you talk about the the incredible
uprising and voices of the students on
this issue what they want is some action
on these ar-15s and do you think
anything is going to happen in that
category john here's the thing that
Republicans control the house they
control the Senate and they control the
White House and and the political
reality that we're living in today is if
President Trump does not get behind
something they won't have they won't
have the cover they think or they feel
comfortable with as far as voting so
we're gonna go to the White House today
I'm going to lay out the piece of
legislation Pat Toomey will be there
John Cornyn the fix Nick's bill which is
part of our bill but John's come out
with it separately imported aside were
for that what for all of that
strengthening as far as making sure the
database is up you know has been updated
making sure that we're doing everything
that we can to identify a threat and if
so many signals were missed there that
can't happen so there's a lot of things
that we can build off of but you know
bump stocks is a no-brainer
the president's talked about that
there's so many things that can't be
done just make sense we're not doing
anything doesn't make sense to your what
you said there were so many things that
don't make sense and still they do they
don't go forward but let's talk about
people being woke as you just said a
minute ago these teenagers are speaking
up it does feel different this time
Dick's Sporting Goods just announced
this morning they will no longer sell
assault rifles at their stores and they
won't sell any type of gun to anyone
under the age of 21 what do you think
about that as a member of the NRA well
here's the thing you gal that's the
market responding okay and the market
has to move there's an old saying follow
the money well if the market believes
that this is the direction they're going
to go in order to capture and keep their
base I by Dick's Sporting good I'm going
to continue to shop at Dick's Sporting
Goods and buy their I've always done
that so they took a position they think
that that's a position they can take and
sustain there will be others and when
you see Airlines and all this going on
right now and different companies
disassociated themselves they're saying
the NRA that I knew growing up was the
NRA that taught you son safety how to be
responsible this is what we're asking
for again and we're asking the
leadership of the NRA come on come back
to the reality of what we started
there's an old saying dance with who
brung you we learned how to do things
responsibly let's go back to that and
not try to protect do you think assault
rifles should be banned well you know on
that I've said this I don't own an ar-15
nor do I think I have a need to buy one
that's me personally I have other
friends who own them and they have never
done anything or no nor do they intend
to do anything harmful that's a tough
one there but there's not the votes here
to do away with that gal that's the
political reality we're dealing with
senator mentioned we know you have a
really big coming up we will be keeping
eyes on in 24 2018 thanks for your time
well Alex thank you but do you know what
the election it just do your thing do
the right thing the best politics is
good government do the right thing it'll
work out thank Senator Manchin I was
lucky your video today